je vous disais les prochaines stations
du chemin de croix des bosniaques
musulmans s'appelle zepa et gora de ces
deux enclaves en principe protégés par
l'onu la situation semble ce soir
particulièrement critique à ses pas dans
l'est de la bosnie stéphane magnier les
serbes de bosnie ont dès qu'ils
attaqueraient à 14 heures ils ont été
ponctuées et les images de ce
bombardement ressemble certainement à
celle ci prise il ya cinq jours par les
serbes lors de l'offensive contre
srebrenica
c'est d'ailleurs exactement la même
méthode qui est utilisée pilonnages
d'artillerie d'abord progression des
blindés
ensuite contre la plus petite des trois
enclave située à une trentaine de
kilomètres au sud de srebrenica
là aussi la france il se fait par le sud
là encore les casques bleus ne sont pas
épargnés ils ont été dépassés par la
ligne de front l'un d'entre eux aurait
été blessé seule différence âgées pas ce
sont des ukrainiens les chances de
résister agepa sont quasi nulles la zone
a été démilitarisée il y a deux ans j'ai
pas tombera sous peu je tends quinze
mille réfugiés de plus sur les routes
ce sera ensuite sans doute le tour de la
troisième et dernière enclave gore hd ou
les musulmans ont voulu reprendre leurs
armes lourdes pour se défendre
les casques bleus les en ont